let's talk about impeachment but in a
slightly different way we've been
talking about the possibility of Donald
Trump getting impeached the pros the
cons what might cause this to happen
like the possibility of him having
committed obstruction of justice with
the firing of James Comey asking James
Comey to drop the Michael Flint
investigation now we found out what he
told the Russians that he was less
concerned about the investigation after
firing James Comey these are all actions
by Donald Trump that point to him trying
to impact the Russia investigation this
could lead to an impeachment okay if
impeachment proceedings happened they
probably still wouldn't happen for a
while but we've learned that the White
House is preparing for impeachment they
are starting to research impeachment to
White House officials that were briefed
on the situation said that the White
House attorneys are beginning to do
research and prepare for how they will
defend the president against the
possible impeachment proceeding these
lawyers are consulting legal experts who
specialize in impeachment procedures the
officials say that this has been going
on for about a week and we found out
early last week that Donald Trump's
personal lawyer Michael Cohen already a
questionable character that we've talked
about on the show before actually
visited the White House to talk to Trump
about needing to hire personal lawyers
for himself if the White House wasn't
worried at all about impeachment Pat
they wouldn't be doing this right yeah I
think this is one of the few cases of
the White House allocating the resources
in the proper areas because if it wasn't
a threat they wouldn't they wouldn't put
their money and their attention into
this they would be focusing on the
merits of a travel ban or trying to
protect from Trump's financial
disclosures all of these other things
although when I read about this it
crossed my mind
maybe Trump called in lawyers and said
hey can we research how we could impeach
obama somehow that'll really show them
it crossed my mind because with
everything trump has been a sort of
operating on the idea of oh they're
doing x let's do x to them and of course
it's not really going to work here
because obama's gone no doubt that part
of the reason they became more concerned
was the appointment of Robert Muller a
special prosecutor right if you're
sitting in the White House and you fire
Flynn I'm sorry you fire co me because
of what was going on with the
investigation with Russia etc and then
immediately a special prosecutor is
appointed I can't imagine that that's
thrilling to you yeah it's amazing the
mental gymnastics they're able to
undergo I was watching some one American
news over the weekend we're talking
about how the firing of James Comey
could reopen the Hillary Clinton email
and addressed that that's like a
hardcore right-wing thing right I've
seen a couple clips of that Oh a oann
the one American news network or
something like that
yes phenomenal as if she's even relevant
at this point Friday it was leaked by
someone that the Justice Department that
the FBI started looking into the
cover-up of the entire investigation
thing and as we know from history often
it's not the transgression itself but
the cover-up that gets people and we
will see if that happened here when you
think about it
impeachment might actually be a better
move for the Republican Party than for
the Democratic Party I'm not going to
totally rehash that we did we did that
story in the first segment of the show
but we are going to continue following
very closely if there's a certain point
at which the Republican voter base turns
on Trump that would be when so-called
fair-minded Republicans which really
just means political opportunists that
will take advantage of Trump being
unpopular that's when the so-called
fair-minded Republicans would be better
better served by saying we're going to
do the right thing for our country
rather than for our party and support
impeachment of Donald Trump it may not
happen because Trump's approval is still
sticking up there 38 39 % yeah I think
Trump's approval ratings would have to
get into the 20s or so before the
Republicans in Congress decide on mutiny
and take the ship back I think it right
I don't think at 38 percent as
embarrassing it is to have an entire
presidency with your approval rating
between 36 and 42 percent I don't think
at that point Republicans are going to
bail on Donald Trump